dans tous les aspects de ce trou sur
chris pas chopper simulateur de black
friday on avait fait le 1 les dernières
photos logique en soi les ces partis une
nouvelle partie alors la chance de trois
persos la femme qui fait un peu sommes
finalement et une femme qui se remet les
choses en place
après s'être déboîté l apprendre 7,6 à
prendre celle ci c'est parti on veut
jouer on veut jouer donnez nous des
quêtes 27 novembre 2015 c'est le
vendredi des sols attention tout mathieu
hausse à l'ags
oh là là le jeu le mois optimisée du
monde j'avoue ça vous dit aubé un peu de
respect mais pas si je vois les moissons
pour stand réduction attend que wall et
je cassais seule voix game c'est faux ça
se voit que c'est genk a fait mieux
puisque c'est totalement faux c'est le
seul magasin le jour des soldes le
voyais à personne bref en chef tinghir
et une pièce de grandes fleurs ngô
inside non ma ville s'y tromper de
magasins non mais vraiment achats fitch
et vous faire une teinte alors on va
aller dedans et on verra s'il faut faire
par contre les gardes serveur nas à
changer de métier sous plaire il faut
qu'on prenne ok tu as gagné c'est mon
calme toi jean louis voilà je suis
mauvais joueurs s'est dégagée faut que
je grave un truc un truc vert c'est ça
ben voila cela est fait info j'amène à
la caisse et que je paye 30 $ us et shut
up
voilà cela est fait oui est ce qu'on
doit faire pour mettre toute note une là
dedans il faut qu'on achète une énorme
télé faut trouver tvn curie déjà un
magasin qui vend des télés à côté du
curry c'est pas normal après je souligne
juste lui ôter vécu rires ah oui c'est
vraiment ça c'est ce qu'on a le salé
gage sa [ __ ] où est la grosse grosse
télé s'il vous plaît alcee l
c'est faux scandaleux c'est scandaleux
hawat l est et aurait alors oui la
grosse grosse télé s'il vous plaît
regardez c'est celle-là à 42 [ __ ] qu
aux places ça c'est fait et toi dégage
avec ton pc là tu t'excites avec ton
petit corps ne lâche tu fermes ta fait
maintenant [ __ ] c'est pour ça qu'on
éduque les gens on doit le magasin pète
provocateur c'est quoi ce délire du
terrible ce job ou comme sex son petit
string posé sur le canapé dégage pas
pardon ah c'est ça 75 dollars mr va pas
assez d'argent pour acheter un vieux
masques en plastique de charme et quelle
arnaque at on va braquer la caisse
ensuite on va payer avec
heini de dollars dollars toi je peux te
voler toi oh pardon excusez moi les gens
et ce quelqu'un pourrait me faire un don
pour j'achète le masque en plastique
pourri
à tort est également fort toi toi tu
fais des spectacles oui c'est ça était
assis dans le vide mais je veux
apprendre comment tu fais ça excuse moi
quand tu fais ça il suffit que moi tu
peux expliquer ce te plaît comment tu
fais ça se plaît comme tes fesses
comment tu fais ça te plait [ __ ] fais
pas ta [ __ ] c'est pas la cote explique
moi je joue de la cud mavs c'est
extraordinaire ce qui se passe tu as
abusé voyage peut vraiment je vous plaît
autant à la violence salut père noël a
les photos père noël mon coeur d'eric je
suis possédé
o o la violence au nom les gens ils sont
olala c'est tellement glauque un gars
allez les enfants via un allié devant
nous j'ai tué la vienne avec mes p aul
assez bon ben may chez macgé masse
argent comment j'ai eu tout cet argent
servira pour les shows attention
attention aux [ __ ] le pot vol plané
franchement c'était beau c'est gracieux
selphy allé au lac étals sanitas okalys
magasin xulu même il se drogue c'est
quoi ça winter ses imprimantes c'est ça
voilà allez hop attend l'hôtel haussier
c'est la lienne revient la [ __ ]
d'alien tu le saches à brax jamais
attendez je fais un test est ce que ça
va faire l'effet balançoire ou bats pas
du tout braz mandat fort que voilà tu es
maintenant mon chien alors qu'est-ce que
je dois prendre ici alors à cet homme
dégage put aller les gens sont agressifs
là le jour des soldes voilà ça c'est
fait le wa party game on peut trouver ou
un party game c'est ici et si les bulles
je passe la loi - [ __ ] pour faire ce
qu'elle veut si on la tire est clair en
tout ça va marcher regarder et c'est ce
qui s'est vraiment passé dans l'histoire
regardez bien c'est un gars qu une
ventouse et pop ça marche et ses filles
devant aix qualité en vente tous des
hommes
ok maintenant on doit aller au magasin
de jouet acheté un requin taille et en
taille réelle
voilà c'est n'importe quoi il n'y a pas
de requins taille réelle mon gars vont
c'est quelqu'un l'a acheté avant moi
assez regard des 1 100 dollars
hop là c'est le film idiot tu puisses en
haut là je suis prix de la photo [ __ ]
on les a tous je suis prêt et voilà je
peux offrir le week end de mettre à mon
neveu il sera vraiment super content où
il ya un besoin j'aimerais acheter un
puzzle soubelet voilà un petit puzzle
pour mon neveu aussi puisque je l'achète
des requins de mètres mais aussi des
petits puzzles au qu'est ce que c'est
que ça dit non c'est un extincteur medio
[ __ ] violence
ça dégage c'est le magasin cv sol c'est
un perceur ben là c'est comme ça qu'on
fait les soldes amer g10 et toutes les
munitions non mais ça va pas le tenir
coi le tir de profil comme ça on doit
trouver une bouteille de desperation 500
$ le parfum bon bah on va devoir faire
du mal à tellement de gens pour avoir
700 dollars non mais les gars 500
dollars c'est juste impossible quoi il
ya des limites
1 18
plus tard aux mondiaux dans les 100
dollars pour acheter le cadeau ultime
pour notre ve ca sera pas avant des
réductions au moins et voilà ça y est
battant poitiers du pop corn et voilà 50
$ 50 $ le pop corn mais c'en est trop
moi quand je me fais attaquer qu'est ce
que je fais je mets des coups de balai
aux gens je lâche mes nerfs ça sent
peut-être dans la caisse que ces 500 $
en biens patata tu te refusera pas sur
ta statue web agence capa 102 sur
christmas shopping simulator rue daudet
c'est pas mal ça vous a plu et puis
j'espère que vous avez acheté tous les
cadeaux de noël nécessaires à la joie de
votre famille mais savoir ianor santé
dans une prochaine vidéo portez vous
bien un chat au monde bis
à